[Music]
so
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here i figured it
out i got it i understand airpods max
now now it took me a couple days of
listening and comparing
and taking notes but i got it so the
original question when these headphones
were surprise announced was
why is apple making
550 dollar wireless noise canceling
headphones they better either sound
incredible or have some kind of unreal
feature to be worth that much over all
the other headphones that we already
know are good right well here's my take
on where these fall
so there's actually two types
of high-end headphones right the first
would be
like reference type like studio grade
actual production headphones so these
are going to be lightweight they're
going to have a super flat sound
signature you're going to wear them for
hours and hours on end and you often
need extra hardware like a mini preamp
or something like that to drive them
they are geared for production and then
on the other side there's just
luxury listening there's just nice
headphones that sound great for music
and and podcasts and movies and and all
kinds of consumer oriented features so
you might have noise cancellation they
might be wireless that's the other type
they're geared for consumption so now
this new pair of very expensive
headphones
i'm glad they didn't call them airpods
studio because they land squarely in
that second section of luxury listening
and it was kind of confusing to pin them
there at first because they do have a
bunch of features and a bunch of really
weird quirks that actually kind of
resemble the other world i'll talk about
those in a minute but
fact is
these headphones
check a set of boxes
that no other set of headphones i've
ever tested can claim to check it's a
really odd combination of pieces here
but let's just start with the design
right off the bat it's metal so these
headphones have aluminum ear cups that
get cold to the touch when you're
outside in the winter and stainless
steel headband frame here and so right
away they've already started to
differentiate themselves because
virtually every other pair of high-end
headphones or really any headphones out
there are made of plastic but this metal
build is dope it's got super tight
tolerances the ear cups are even this
like satin finish which i think would
look even better as matte black apple
why'd you send me the green one and the
telescoping headband doesn't have
notches but it's really smooth and it
takes a lot of pull to move so it feels
high quality too and the button and the
digital crown up top are super nice they
feel really high quality so if the metal
build is so great why are these like the
only pair of headphones doing the metal
thing why are the rest of them all
plastic well turns out the reason you
don't see metal headphones very much is
because all these other headphone
companies have done the research and one
of the primary factors for comfort for
wearing headphones for a long time
is their weight
and
metal is heavy much heavier than plastic
so they've all realized that and they've
all done plastic headphones because
that's so much more comfortable to wear
for a long time so this is something
airpods macs have to work around so they
do their best with this really thin
flexible mesh in the top band that's
supposed to sort of evenly distribute
some of the weight on top of your head
but there's no getting around that these
are heavy headphones it's kind of like
driving an electric car if you keep it
in a straight line you can forget that
it's heavy but as soon as you hit a
corner you remember it's a heavy car and
so for me if i sit still with these
headphones for a while i totally forget
the weight they just kind of sit on my
head like a pillow but the second i nod
my head or stand up to look at something
or look up i remember they're quite
heavy for the numbers people about 380
something grams versus 250 ish grams but
you know what these do a pretty great
job with the metal compared to how it
could have been i have exactly one other
pair of headphones that's made
completely of metal
and it's these
remember these these are the beats pros
400 bucks all metal headphones and they
bragged about how they're all metal
and these did a terrible job with it
these weigh
450 grams or something like that they're
way heavier and
they're about the least comfortable pair
of headphones i've ever worn they pinch
you right on the right underneath your
ear they're on ear for some reason
instead of over ear
harsh
they're brutal
they squeeze your head like a lot unless
your head is shaped like this which it's
not so
yeah it could have been a lot worse but
then some other quick design notes there
is no apple logo anywhere on these
headphones so the design is actually
it's actually kind of grown on me over
the past few days it looks pretty clean
and like i said matte black would look
pretty sweet and also you should know
there's no sweat or water resistance
here so if you're an athlete or if
you're looking to make these your gym
headphones you want to walk around the
city while it's raining or snowing or
something like that
probably reconsider apple went with
over-ear headphones here instead of
on-ear and i definitely prefer this the
mesh ear cups with memory foam are nice
and soft and very comfortable and
through long listening sessions they've
actually done better than leather i
listen to more than two three hours in a
row before my ears start to get hot and
i needed a break which is pretty great
and the ear cups
are removable
easily with magnets now this is a quirk
you pretty much never see in consumer
headphones but the fact is you really
should be somewhat regularly replacing
the actual ear cup part of your
headphones that you keep for a long time
but most people never do but here it
makes sense you know these are going to
be metal headphones that will hopefully
last you a long time many many years of
use but this piece that you want to stay
the same will eventually compress and
start to crack and get old and faded you
get a new pair it keeps the driver the
same distance from your ear all that
good stuff just by replacing it now
apple's going to sell you replacements
for
69 bucks which
is definitely overpriced there's no way
they're worth that much money but i got
to give them credit for the system here
at least they're easy to replace and you
can mix and match colors if you want to
the lack of touch controls i think were
a good call here on the airpods max
apple added a larger version of that
digital crown from the apple watch up
top but basically it's just a fancy knob
that you rotate for volume and press for
media controls and it works great it's
got really satisfying clicks and you can
reverse the direction of the spin in ios
software if you want to but alright
marquez they cost 550
they better sound like god himself
whispering in my ear for that much money
how do they sound
well
they sound
like luxury listening which is to say
really really good now listen i'm gonna
preface this by saying i'm not an
audiophile like probably every other
review at this time but
i've listened to a lot of headphones at
this point i know what i like and these
sound really good airpods macs have
these big 40 millimeter drivers behind
those earcups and they sound excellent
super clear at all volumes i was
impressed by the ultra low distortion at
high volumes too and they do get loud
enough that i should never need to
listen at 100 volume i max out at
probably 75 to 85 percent you obviously
approach the limits of how good things
can sound over wireless when you're just
listening to streaming services and
bluetooth but with high quality spotify
streaming quality i'm loving this solid
punchy bass and even a little deep sub
bass once in a while the instrument
separation is great and the clarity
through mids and highs in a variety of
genres is great not fatiguing at all to
listen to now if you're sitting and
watching this video and thinking well
okay what about some nice higher bitrate
local files
these headphones already aren't for you
like at that level that you're talking
about
you probably want you you end up getting
some extra hardware so a nice preamp
with some nice clean gain to power some
wired headphones probably open back and
some nice single source audio files with
high bit rate and by the time you get
through all of that that's a very
different level of commitment
and work
than someone who just wants to grab some
wireless headphones so you would be
getting some extra quality that you
could hear out of that setup sure
but people listening these headphones
are i'm gonna be totally honest
listening to spotify and apple music
and maybe title but also some soundcloud
and youtube and some some podcasts and
watching some movies so the sound
quality is fantastic for that the noise
cancellation is also excellent now this
i kind of saw coming but these nine
microphones on here do a fantastic job
with white noise and with a surprisingly
natural sound to it sometimes
noise-canceling headphones can feel like
there's a bit of a pressure and they
sound a little bit unnatural with it on
i found that these didn't do much of
that whether it's because of the mesh or
the pass-throughs or the mics whatever
it's all awesome and obviously i haven't
gotten to fly with these yet but it
absolutely cancelled out a vacuum
cleaner like three feet away from my
head so i'm gonna put these right up as
matching the sony xm4s as kings of noise
cancellation and they should be great on
a plane and these headphones also have
the best
transparency mode
i've ever heard and you know obviously
other noise canceling headphones will do
this they'll have a mode where you can
let ambient sound through so you can
hear your environment someone calls you
or someone your bus stop gets read out
loud or something like that
but these for whatever reason
are incredible i can hear everything but
not just
what things are being said but where
they're coming from or some things to my
right to my left in front of me behind
me
a lot of other headphones have an
ambient mode
these are the king of that so all of
that translates to these being
fun to listen to there's no latency or
range issues anywhere with bluetooth so
i'm able to walk around corners and even
up and down stairs away from my device
without a drop connection and also you
might be wondering how the audio would
sound with these nine microphones
picking up your voice and cancelling out
the background noise so
this is how it would sound
it's fine
there's not a lot of background noise
even this time but if you're on a zoom
call or a facetime and these are your
microphone is what you're gonna get all
right we gotta talk about this case
this
stupid case i hate
everything about this i hate the way it
looks i hate these sloppy kind of
pointless slots across the bottom i hate
that the lightning port doesn't quite
line up at the bottom in that notch
cutout i hate that they're annoying to
take the headphones out of quickly and
they're annoying to put the headphones
back into i hate that the magnet is kind
of small in the lip and it's kind of
easy to miss sometimes and it's not as
satisfying to slap it shut i hate that
it doesn't protect easily the most
delicate part of the headphones that
needs protection that mesh headband i
hate that it looks like a mini purse and
i hate that i know apple thoroughly
considered all this stuff i hate that
there's no off button on these
headphones and that it requires you to
put them in this stupid case to trigger
the low power mode so it doesn't just
burn through battery all the time
now don't get me wrong
the battery life on these headphones
is fine they do reach the advertised i
would say 16 to 20 hours even with noise
cancellation on and you can plug them in
for five minutes and get an hour and a
half of extra listening so the battery
is not a problem
but this case is so stupid it's just
this it's just a weird choice very
apple-like choice to to lock you into
their magical solution for
they turn on and they just work when you
want them to because now you have to use
this case like if i don't want to use
this case when they sit out they drain
battery at about the same rate as when
they're on and playing music whether
they are playing or not even though they
know they're not on your head and
they'll do that for about two hours
staying ready to go until they
automatically go into low power mode
but aside from that dumb case there's
plenty of smart features built in here
the sensors inside will know if they're
on your head or not and will auto play
pause when you take them off and put
them back on you can hold that digital
crown you can talk to siri all you want
she'll read out your text messages and
talk to you and of course all the
awesomeness of airpods pairing to every
apple device you have instantly is still
pretty sweet so you can quickly switch
between your mac your iphone and your
ipad if you have one solid and then some
last little housekeeping stuff from
those of you who left comments on the
impressions video what you wanted to
know uh can you use these with android
just as normal bluetooth headphones
yes you can but at this point you're
cutting off a lot of the smart features
so
seems not worth it
how's the bleed they do bleed a little
bit so if you've got these up at say 75
85 volume or higher people around you
can actually hear what you're listening
to
and do they still work when the battery
is dead if they're plugged in
yes they do
but at the end of the day
this all comes down to what you want
headphones to do so like i mentioned at
the beginning of this video there's a
separate
section of high-end headphones that are
reference grade professional production
headphones
and you could use these for that but i
personally wouldn't i mean these are not
flat uh you can't turn adaptive eq off
you can't turn the colorful sound off
and it just doesn't have the production
stuff built in they're not wired they're
not open back they're just
they're not really for that but what
these are meant to do is deliver a great
listening experience
and with their awesome sound quality
they do and with their sweet noise
cancellation they do with their pretty
cool spatial audio experience which only
works with iphones and ipads for now but
is basically the same as uh airpods pro
it'll pick up on
7.1 and dolby atmos
sound sources and will sort of respond
to your head placement based on where
you're at it's awesome for movies that
is so great as a listening experience
the wireless connection great for
listening i mean all the stuff that
they've built in
the the play pause stuff all the volume
controls it's so that it's a better
listening experience and they do all
this stuff with just a few
gigantic quirks sort of like a top three
giant quirks which are the stupid case
the metal build which is a bit heavy
and that price tag
but if you are okay with those three
things and especially if you're in
apple's ecosystem like we've talked
about so many times well
then these are pretty dope headphones
sounds kind of like a lot of other apple
products right
either way
that's been it airpods max review hope
you enjoyed it's kind of
tech sember at this rate isn't it lots
of stuff coming up lots of stuff in the
back burners catch you guys very soon in
the next video
peace